donc je ne vois pas comment ce
gouvernement peut continuer de se
regarder dans la glace que ce soit jean
michel blanquer que ce soit monsieur
castex qui était responsable dudit
confinement et que ce soit ce président
qui nous ment devant la caméra qui a
menti
c'était le cas le 14 juillet en disant
que la france serait prête en cas de
deuxième bague et ce soir il a eu le
culot de dire que personne n'a vu venir
cette deuxième vague personne n'a vu
venir l'explosion des cas c'est faux il
n'avait qu'à écouter des médecins le
conseil scientifique tout le monde à peu
près a expliqué que la rentrée ne devait
pas être fait comme ça l'est mais les
professeurs dans les écoles qui étaient
eux très conscient que le coc vide et
est en train d'exploser puisque soit ils
ont été malades eux mêmes soit il avait
plus de trois ou quatre cas dans les
classes encore une fois pas de vagues
il ne fallait pas en parler les
soignants qui ont alerté qui on demande
est toujours plus de moyens qui ont dit
mais qu'est ce que vous faites
finalement c'est ça n'a aucun sens donc
ce monsieur emmanuel macron président de
la république française qui a passé deux
belles vacances rien préparé le voilà
aujourd'hui nous demandant de faire
encore des efforts parce qu'il a été
incapable de nous protéger parce qu'il a
été incapable de mettre en place les
mesures qui ferait qu aujourd'hui nous
ne serions pas dans un deuxième
confinement et ce confinement est bien
pour essayer de sauver l'économie mais
ça ne suffira pas malheureusement je le
crains pour de nombreux entrepreneurs
c'est la clé sous la porte
à partir de ce soir de vendredi soir eh
bien il faudra continuer d'aller
travailler on va garder les écoles
ouvertes alors que c'est même là que le
virus se transmet et se propage
donc ça n'a encore une fois aucun sens à
part nous prendre pour des hamsters mais
je le redis encore une fois on ne met
pas un peuple en cage et regarder autour
de nous en espagne en italie un peu
partout ailleurs je crois que partout
les populations en ont ras-le-bol de ces
mesures
idiote qu'ils ne comprennent pas parce
que le virus continue et parce que la
réponse c'est qu'il fallait avoir
c'était éviter le contact la rentrée
comme elle a été organisée
testez isolé faire en sorte que les
chaînes de reproduction du virus soit
cassé très tôt tout ça n'a pas été fait
et qu'est ce qu'il reste pour nos
gouvernants le confinement c'est à dire
empêcher les gens empêcher et et finir
mettre en terre la liberté ce
gouvernement est morbide les cimetières
vous restait ouvert mais les parcs vont
encore fermée voilà à peu près la vie
que nous propose
emmanuel macron c'est une vide
moore